[Music]
hello my name is National Master Caleb
Dy and I will be your driver on the road
to 2000 so um first we're going to start
with a calculation exercise and then
we'll end with a calculation exercise um
and in the middle we'll like look at my
games or something um so this position
is um sorry sorry this will be the last
position this is the first position um
white to play and win this is very
simple just to warm you guys
up I'm sure some of you have seen this
before yeah Queen H6 and after King
takes you want what and after Pon takes
you want all right now don't forget this
I'm going to trick you later so this uh
this is very simple um so basically in
chess there are two things you need to
master you need to get good at pattern
recognition which is basically just um
you know problems that you've abstracted
away and you need to get get uh good at
visualization so how many moves ahead
can you see in a game of chess those are
the main two skills the chess players
have um okay I'm going to get into my
game against Kad and
trough because uh another thing you
should do if you're trying to improve a
chest is you should analyze your losses
and this game um this game was
rough uh Kaden's a tough opponent and uh
I was never better this game he just he
just was slowly strangling me um I have
a lot of analogies I could I could use I
will I will um I will not use any of
them I'd rather go to the the dentist
than relive this
experience um anyway he played Knight F3
I played Pawn to C5 implying that I'm
okay with him playing E4 and we'll get
into some kind of Sicilian he played the
move G3 I play G6 uh the opening is not
so important these days I actually don't
really care about the opening too much I
just play whatever um doesn't matter who
I play I just do whatever um the thing
that matters later is like how well do
you play later in the game not how well
you play in the first like 15 moves so
my opponent castled my opponent played
Knight C6 it's also nice that my
opponent selected this kind of opening
because I can get away with this style
of play a lot more than if he played
something slightly more theoretical my
opponent plays the move E3 okay um this
is maybe the first interesting moment
because um okay E3 is an unusual move
how would you guys like to react to it
what do you want to
do
get well me too but
how D5 yeah so I played the move D5
five um how are you planning on getting
rid of his light squared Bishop just out
of curiosity I want to know because if I
can do that I'm going to do
it okay he plays the move
d4 all right Bishop to G5 Bishop to G4
probably is the intention um so in the
game I played CD4 um Bishop to G4 uh one
thing you're going to have to consider
uh is the move D capture C5 so this is
like the big intention that white has
because he might hit you with some Pawn
to C4 I'm sorry knight5 Knight
E5 okay you play Knight to E5 I don't
know I can continue Knight D2
maybe right well play Knight takes
Knight mhm and E5 and E5 okay so if you
do something like this I think that um
after Pawn H3 uh you have like a lot it
seems like you have a lot of development
in your controlling the center at the
moment but if you move your Bishop back
like let's say I don't know F F6 or
sorry F5 or E6 I'm not sure if you put
your Bishop on E6 um it's exposed to
like Knight G5 later so for instance I
might play E4 and if you take me the
Knight G5 is is interested
um as well as Queen d8 and Knight G5 if
you put your Bishop on F5 then C4
becomes stronger because obviously the
C4 Pawn is not protected so if you take
me I will give this kind of check and
white will generate some kind of
initiative here that you might not be
happy with um yeah so I mean even so
Queen D7 might be clever because if I
take you then you might like have some
trick but a position that looks like
this one is a Catalan player's dream
like basically White's Kee is safe this
this bishop is a monster this Bishop's
blocked in by the pawn on E5 um this is
no this is no fun for
black uh so I would like to trade light
squid Bishops I don't think it's a super
realistic thing for me to do I instead
took the pawn on D4 um with uh the
expectation that my opponent would play
the move e captures D4 maybe a little uh
naively from my perspective um my
opponent instead play Knight takes D4 if
had my opponent played the move C
captures D4 then my intention was indeed
to play the move Bishop to G4 like you
wanted but there's no C captures sorry
DC capture C5 right so Knight takes D4
is a very serious consideration from uh
from
black um okay so black takes on D4 and
this is the next interesting moment um
whether I chose correctly or not is is
Up For Debate but um you have more or
less two choices
do we still play Knight takes D4 and go
for these reverse Carl bat structures or
do we just do nothing or make some
improving move such as Knight
F6 so
forth and what about E5 here yeah so E5
is in interesting
um the thing is I I sort of expected on
most moves that my opponent would be
Capt on C6 and E5 makes capturing on C6
stronger because in these grunfeld
positions when white plays or reverse
Grell positions when white plays the
move Pawn to C4 you would really like to
be able to play E6 such that D5 is not a
real Target but here your Center is kind
of coming under Fire
right this is maybe maybe something you
should care
about okay in the game I played Knight
to F6 my reasoning was if I play Knight
takes Pawn takes and then something like
Knight F6 it is kind of awkward uh to
put this bishop on a reasonable Square
whereas my opponent can this bishop is
pretty good right the bishop on on G2 is
targeting the pawn on D5 if he plays
Pawn to C3 then he's playing against my
uh Bishop on G7 and I didn't really
believe in this minority uh attack idea
uh in in conjunction with G6 Bishop G7
uh with that said I've played a bunch of
caro in my life and in the exchange K
when I was like 17 18 that like kind of
age I would play G6 all the time and if
my opponent played G3 I'd be like pretty
happy so this uh this isn't like
necessarily the most dangerous setup so
maybe it's just a different way of
playing but I figured the most critical
move was just to ignore him I have two
Center pawns after all play Knight F6 if
you try to attack the D5 Pawn maybe I
can reinforce it with E6 later okay my
opponent played the move Pawn to C4 and
then you you know me being me I made a
mistake
immediately so um what a normal person
should do uh is you know like follow the
opening principles in Castle instead I
thought I was being very clever I played
the move Bishop to
G4 and uh uh White has um only one good
response but the response is you know
pretty obvious and also pretty good so
what would you guys like to do with
white
Tom G suggests Queen to B3 but Queen to
B3 is actually a mistake and now it is
black to play and gain a very serious
advantage
Knight takes Knight Knight takes Knight
yeah after Knight takes Knight Pawn
takes your D5 Pawn is hanging your B7
Pawn is hanging maybe maybe you're not
worse oh this is this is your idea I see
but I mean still like Rook E1 you take
on C4 I take on B7 moves like Knight A3
are
coming maybe you're not worse but you're
probably not better I mean E7 is also
hanging
so there's a there's a punishing move
to uh to Queen B3 Queen B3 is just an
outright
mistake yeah so Knight A5 attacks the
queen it protects the pawn and it
attacks this Pawn so it's probably a
pretty good move so the question is what
happens if white gives some kind of
check right this is the most critical
move albeit maybe not the
best B yeah Bishop D7 and all of White's
pieces are hanging I'm going to play
Knight C4 next and uh yeah I mean
White's position is no good so Queen B3
is not the response but white has a
pretty good move here that's like pretty
aggressive and kind of obvious that
punishes Bishop G4 in a harsh
way I can't stop thinking about F3 F3
never play
F3 um well I actually wanted him to play
F3 this was sort of the point behind
Bishop G4 I'll I'll just like go away
and this Catalan Bishop that's so
powerful in all these positions has kind
of been blunted right yeah so
positionally I thought this was
advantageous for
Me Maybe White's position isn't terrible
but probably white isn't
better
yeah so Queen A4 is what he
played um
now one thing that's that's irritating
is uh we would like to just like Castle
here and if white plays um maybe the
most straightforward way I don't know
what guys consider to be the most
straightforward but let's say Knight
takes C6 Pawn takes C6 Queen C6 and then
Rook C8 uh it's pretty obvious that
white is not better here I mean of
Black's P pieces are out we're about to
win the C4 Pawn back uh and even if you
win A7 Black's can to have like a ton of
compensation but white after castles
will play C captures D5 first and if I
take on D5 the Knight C6 wins a piece
right G4 is just
hanging and if I take on D4 after Queen
takes D4 there are no useful discoveries
in fact the queen is a monster on D4
just protecting the D5 Pawn White's
about to develop and achieve a a pretty
good
position okay so after Queen A4 um it is
now black to play and
find um find the best
move your opponent has played Queen A4
yeah you're you're an idiot for playing
Bishop G4 but still got to play chess
moves what to
do
chess lover has got it yeah the move is
Bishop to
D7 but the real question is what do you
do after C captures
D5 how can we justify Bishop to
D7 believe it or not this was my
intention when my opponent played when I
played the move is G4 which maybe is a
little
silly what about Knight to e E5 Knight
to E5 so if you play Knight E5 your
opponent will play Queen B3 protecting
D5 attacking
B7 it's not super clear where your
compensation's coming from right white
has got the center your knight on E5 is
not super stable either I might play F4
position could get rough really really
fast Knight A5 has been suggested by
chess lover
but I frankly don't even understand that
move like Knight A5 I like go Queen D1
or something like trapping your own
Knight I don't get
it maybe there's some point probably
have some better move too like Knight A5
Queen B4 maybe
unclear
B5 and you guys are more aggressive than
I am and that's saying
something B5 what if I like okay so the
point is very clear I suppose after B5
you're saying to me um I if I take your
Pawn you're taking my knight and winning
the game uh although I'm not sure like
just like Queen D1 or something like
why why did we do this also you're
asking for trouble like after d C6 Pawn
takes here sorry Pawn takes D7 can't
take with the queen cuz uh you know
Bishop C6 and Bishop A8 both win
depending upon like how sadistic you are
and King D7 Bishop C6 I mean i' I've
seen better positions up a
queen
maybe yeah oh sorry sorry Knight yeah
Knight D7 oh Knight D7 does exist yeah
but okay this is unnecessary after B5
I'll play Queen Queen D1 and and you
will probably
suffer now In fairness to you guys you
were not the idiots that played Bishop
G4 Bishop
D7 it's all on me I'm just asking you to
justify my
myths we actually can avoid losing
material some what
surprisingly Queen
A5 the problem with Queen
A5 there might be many problems with
Queen A5 but Queen A5 I mean if I just
like take your queen you're still down
on Pawn right you need to prove your
compensation and Frankly Speaking I mean
White's pieces are pretty good right
like maybe white is even better um if
the material were were equal
right it's hard to
say I'll give you a hint these two
things are lined up right that is bad
alignment for white and we can take
advantage of it on this exact
move now you guys are trying for
immediate Knight discoveries but those
Knight discoveries don't attack anything
what we what we would like to do is play
the move Knight takes D4 however after
Knight takes D4 Queen takes D4 nothing
bad happens to White knight5 yeah Knight
takes D5 is what I played and um in this
position my opponent captured on C6 I
was thinking oh if my opponent takes
makes me then look how clever I am I
play um Knight to D4 and if you play
Queen to C4 which I thought was maybe a
logical thing to do um I mean it isn't
actually then Bishop to B5 and I think I
just win the game because that's haing
that's Hing that's coming this is check
and probably I have other better
moves um even if you play a move like
Queen to D1 um I much like yourself
wanted to uh trade off his light squared
Bishop so a move like Bishop C6 comes to
mind and um this is maybe the worst Pawn
in history to try to
win because you're going to get hit with
something I mean I can also take back D4
um and if you take on C6 and I play
Knight takes
C6 um black is very clearly for Choice
here right I have two pieces out you got
that going on I'm about to Castle the
thing that was guarding your kingside no
longer exists so I'm pretty happy
um but Kaden you know being a pretty
good player uh plays plays the move um
Knight takes C6 which is uh hyper
accurate and after Bishop C6 um again
thinking from um our opponent's
perspective although right now it's his
turn uh so probably we should have
thought this way like a while ago um
what would you do with
white
Queen B3 Queen B3 is a very strong move
Queen B3 threatens uh the Knight and the
pawn or sorry is putting pressure on the
knight in the pawn doesn't threaten
anything um okay now you might be
thinking hey Julian what if I just like
Castle don't I have all my pieces out
and white like has this going on but if
you Castle then white wins the game
immediately so White's play and
win yeah Rook to D1 and there's uh
there's nothing in this world that you
can do to stop Pawn to
E4 after Pawn E4 you're going to be in
pain so I didn't do that I played the
move Pawn E6 because I wanted to meet
Rook to Rook to D1 with the move Queen
to B6 for instance um amongst other
things uh probably I was going to go
Queen E7 actually um and I wanted to
like castle if I go Queen B6 then maybe
Queen A3 is annoying Maybe not maybe I
can like do this and then go back who
knows um at any rate my opponent played
the move Pawn E4 which is stronger
because it misplaces my knight I put my
knight on B6 play Knight C3 this is like
very Grand masterly play right like uh
your opponent has played for like a few
tricks you dissolved all the tricks and
now as white you just have a very nice
Advantage white has more space than
black um and the play is just easier
right because after I Castle um white is
ready to put his Rooks on the open lines
in fact he has the option here to play
Rook to D1 uh which he chose not to do
he played Bishop E3 I I think his
reasoning was um potentially his Rook
was more useful on E1 so after Bishop E3
he has the option to play Rook a to D1
and
generally um when you're choosing
between like different positional ideas
you want to play the move that you're
always going to play over the moves you
may or may not play White is um
virtually always going to play Bishop E3
like all the other squares are soft
Bishop F4 gets exposed to like E5 ideas
um Bishop G5 is unplayable Bishop H6 is
unplayable Bishop D2 even if it were
possible doesn't make any sense
so Bishop E3 is what white wants to do
it's not super clear if White's Rooks
are better on D1 and C1 or E1 and D1
that isn't clear yet so Bishop E3 is
just a better move okay um I played the
move Queen to D3 which is
um which was based off of some
calculation that was incorrect it's an
okay move but the the the calculation
was a little suspicious uh my opponent
oh oops
that's not quite what I wanted to
do okay so Queen D3 my opponent played
Rook F to D1 all
right so um what would you guys like to
do with
black
MH okay your opponent goes Queen A3 so
Queen C2 I have like a pretty good
response um which is Bishop sorry sorry
I should make you find it black to play
and win after Queen
C2 Bishop yeah Bishop A4 and these two
things are lined up poorly if you play
the move B3 I have Queen C3 everything
is hanging takes takes the Rook on A1 is
is attacked right um and if you take
this way then your queen is obviously
obviously
attacked okay
and sorry
so if you play B3 then you take
there so if you're on C2 you play
B3
M yeah so he he he can't take this piece
because this queen is under attack right
so he's down a piece right now if you
take me I'll take you
backie no you you'll end up um with a
rook for for a you'll have two Bishops
in compensation for being down the
exchange but you are down the exchange
here yeah actually now I think about it
maybe you have like Rook C1 or something
but I mean okay
frankly even Rook C8 in this position
where I'm up a pawn like black is
obviously pretty happy to achieve this
okay my opponent didn't do that my
opponent played the move Queen
A3 what is my opponent's
threat fans of Ben fold should find this
move
immediately if you say F3 you are
[Music]
incorrect my opponent does have a move
what would you like to do yes chess
levers got it immediately of course the
threat is Bishop F1 trapping the
queen okay now my my calculation which
started like back here you know this is
the problem with calculation um I was
like yeah I go Queen D3 my opponent goes
there that makes sense I go here my
opponent goes there um I was thinking um
I will take his dude okay this position
where we have no Queens on the board and
I get to play Knight C4 I think is
pretty obviously nothing for
white like the C4 Square should be good
enough compensation for the bishop
pair and if you just take take me back
um I wanted to play the move Bishop E4
which blunders what
tactic sorry didn't hear the question
what tactic does Bishop E4 blunder which
I I
saw Rook D4 Fork yes that is correct now
Rook D4 is a terrible move because I
take on G2 you take on C4 I take you
back your Queen's attacked your Bishop's
attacked you know you do this and I go
away and I don't care who you are I'm
not going to lose to you here I may be
down a queen but everything's about to
be protected you go H4 I'll go H5 you
put your Rook somewhere I'll I mean I
can even because you're checkmated I can
go rook d8 and after I put my Pawn on A6
it is literally impossible for you to
make any more progress um in fact maybe
even black is for choice no matter what
the computer says because everything's
protected and it's going to be really
hard for you to generate any kind of
play okay so um my
opponent uh sorry I didn't do this what
I realized is after Bishop C3 Pawn C3 um
if I take on e4 my opponent is going to
play the move Bishop F1 and just not
take me back and the fact that my
opponent has a dark squar Bishop is
terrifying like I am I'm getting very
close to checkmated here right my
opponent goes like Queen E7 Bishop H6
queen queen F6 is on the agenda for
instance Rook E8 Queen F6 is something I
was looking at um here I have Knight D5
uh which might save my life um but I was
I was getting scared and honestly um
when I checked the game afterwards with
the
computer uh it was like yeah you should
do this and then find the move E5 and
black is actually doing uh doing all
right here um black is is not worse
because uh you have the C4 Square in
compensation for uh the bishop hair and
uh you're not getting checkmated after I
like kick you out I mean it's very
surprising to play E5 there all of your
dark SES well it makes sense right
because we're actually giving ourselves
a square for with with the queen um a
big thing is uh sorry a big thing the
reason why we took on C3 is we can meet
Bishop F1 all the time with the move
Queen
E4 so why would lose if I managed to
play the move Queen E4 um if if I were
to play some random improving move then
after Bishop F1 E4 is defended and
therefore I will lose the game okay now
I should have gone for something like
that I didn't actually see what was
wrong with it I just got scared and this
is a big this is a big problem I think
with a lot of people's chest including
including my own um you see a variation
and you don't know like if it's right or
wrong and then you like get scared for
no reason um if you don't actually see
the reason why something is right or
wrong you have to play it and lose like
that's just chess like imagine your
opponent gives you a pawn and you know
in the back of your mind you're like all
right I can't take that pawn because of
like
some you know fear preconceived notion
about how chess Works unless you can
actually justify it to yourself with
like hard um logic and reasoning you
have to take that
pawn that's that's just how that's just
how chess works um so I should have done
this and unless I had some concrete
variation here I should have uh kept
playing the thing I was looking at was
like Queen E7 and so forth and I got
scared um I this is how I how I should
have played anyway instead I play the
move Queen A6 which is very obviously a
bailout move black does not want to play
Queen A6 when you play the move Queen A6
after Queen takes B takes this bishop no
longer has a stable home right all of
Black's pieces kind of make sense um
except the queen is like kind of Trapped
um besides the queen every other piece
makes a ton of sense right this Bishop's
a monster this Bishop's attacking uh E4
the Knight on B6 can come to C4 later uh
the Queen's the only thing that's like
really out of play even Rook d8 Rook C8
makes a ton of sense Queen A6 Queen
takes now all of a sudden your structure
is worse than whites and more
importantly the bishop on C6 is not
stable so we took a position that was
like interesting and complicated and
then made it like very clearly worse um
now the reason why I did this um I was
very happy to draw this game um my
opponent is better than me and also if I
made a draw we would be like two rating
points away from FM if we didn't
actually like hit FM so this is this is
like a big deal to me at the time um and
but okay Queen A6 B A6 and then my
opponent plays Bishop D4 which is very
nice if my opponent lets me play the
move Rook
fd8 then you know the position is is
okay I mean the bishop on g7's pretty
good I might be able to play Knight C4
instead he plays Bishop D4 which is nice
trading off one of my few good pieces I
played Rook fd8 anyway trades and Bishop
F1 pointing out that A6 is weak okay I
pushed the pawn because it was attacked
Rook
fc1 traded on D1 um I'm trying to reduce
material as much as possible because if
everything stays the same I am going to
lose eventually to um him either taking
my a pawn and then winning 2V1 or he's
going to invade on the seventh rank or
something to that effect so I calculated
a sequence which was Rook D1 you must
take with the Rook Knight takes is not
feasible on account of Bishop E4 Rook
takes D1 Knight A4 Knight takes A4
Bishop takes A4 Rook C1 Rook B8 um
attacking the B2 Pawn this is just some
very concrete analysis Bishop B5 um
everything I did was like on Tempo so I
calculated it from the start so I
calculated it from Rook takes D1 so
Knight A4 came with a threat you know so
on um and then we achieved this end game
now in my mind I thought this end game
would be like pretty easy to defend
because even though I have a worse
structure than my opponent and
technically my Rook is worse than his if
I manage to go A4 with black like let's
say white plays something like King G2
and uh black plays the move Pawn A4
after B takes and Rook A5 or B4 doesn't
really matter um yeah I mean why would
why would black be worse here right
everything's now the
same uh so you're now Grandmaster Kaden
trough what would you like to do with
whites r c Rook C4 Rook
C4 stops me from playing the move Pawn
day
A4 can on
that's pretty uncomfortable the worst
part about Rook C4 um is it's uh like I
have the option of going Rook B4 and
going into a pawn in game which requires
calculation but requires no calculation
from him because either he'll win or is
a draw there's no losing for him but uh
what do you guys think is Rook B4 an
okay Pawn end game or is it is it
losing and if so
why we don't want to stay in the current
position the current position is kind of
bad for
us well you have to do some calculation
right can't just say
it you're trying to get me to play Rook
B4 without calculating against a
Grandmaster it's very mean of
you I think I think just Rook takes rook
and then you got a lost has
yeah that's right so chess lever and you
got the same answer so Rook B4 just
loses because after captures captured uh
the king is going to end up on C4 so
King F1 King E2 King D3 and if the king
manages to get to the square which it
very obviously will um that is a key
square and white does win the
game
um
actually yeah so here um maybe maybe
King D4 is even smarter you're going to
have to um out
uho out Tempo me but it's going it's
going to be really rough it's not going
to it's not going to work out for
you
um okay
instead I played the move K F6 because I
want to activate my
can cane F1 and then Pawn A6 the reason
why I played A6 was I wanted to play
King E5 but after King
E5 my opponent has the option of going
Rook C7 which attacks the F7 pawn and
the A7 Pawn so I was okay with him going
Rook C7 but not in a position where he
could capture the A7
Pawn so oh sorry Pawn A6 King E2 King
E5 Pawn
F4 so this
position um I was sort of happy to
achieve during the game because I
figured after King D6 I'm guarding all
the entry squares uh that are relevant
for his Rook if if Rook C it doesn't
really matter because um I mean if he
tries to attack F7 I can just come back
and guard it attacks H7 I'll move it and
if he moves away I have this A4 and Rook
B4 idea still so I should be doing all
right okay my opponent plays E5 which is
also like a very Grand masterly move
like just permanent advantage
this structure is fundamentally better
than this structure the reason for that
is if white manages to put his keing on
F6 I
lose it's not like I hold it's not like
oh it's interesting no the game's over
my opponent gets his King to F6 doesn't
matter what kind of end game we're in we
could be in a king and pawn ending or
rook and pawn ending the game just
ends so because he has like such a good
um grip on the king side I'm going to
have to watch out on the king side and
the queen side and uh very famously in
these sorts of end games you need two
weaknesses right so he's in a sense
trying to create a second weakness on
the king
side okay um still King D7 is good
guards guards these squares I mean
objectively the game is still a draw
King D3 I played Rook D5 this King and
pawn ending is different why is this
different it actually doesn't matter if
I play King C6 or
not so like if I take
uh yeah so like let's say I take and
then go King C6 and you go King C4 why
is this okay for
black yeah my
my yeah my next moves are B6 King B6 C6
B6 C6 I mean what are you going to do
the only way that white wins is by
putting his King on the king side but in
a pure kingan Pawn ending as soon as the
king arrives to G4 what do you
do you have a defense H6
H6 it's like what is black actually
going to do to you now right I mean H4
he could try but I mean this is also
risky since this a king and pawn ending
you've you've gotten rid of the piece
that I'm afraid of like the piece I was
afraid of was the one that was going
over there and taking my stuff right um
if I can go King C5 B4 A3 and then like
take your queen side I might win the
game that would be that would be awful
um also even pretending for a second
that I don't do that like let's say that
I just like pass around like I just wait
around if you um think about
it as soon as this happens like the only
only way you're going to break through
is by playing
G5 sorry G5 and after H5 you still don't
have any squares there's no way to break
this structure by itself you need
something else in addition to it now in
rook and pawn endings this is not true
if white can trade off a pawn and a rook
the H Pawn for the G pawn and a rook and
pawn ending I will win by playing Rook
D6 and taking your E Pawn or I'll go
Rook H2 force you to move your H Pawn
and go King
G5 there're two different ways I can win
but in the king of Pawn ending
that's not uh not a plan that will work
out for you so Rook D4 does not win the
game my opponent played K E3 um okay so
what do you do with
black it's still not losing we haven't
lost the game
yet Al although it's not
fun Rook to D1 if you go Rook to D1 your
opponent will play Rook
C5 and if you go Rook D5 back this Pawn
ending it's different because you have
this weakness right so King D4 comes and
now now I'm going to
win and if you don't come back I'm going
to I'm going to take all your
stuff it's real art like doing
nothing it's not easily mastered
all right the other obvious is King D
King d8 but if King d8 then you give
Rook
C6 aha in chat somebody suggested H5
this is this is not a good suggestion
because white will come up with the
following plan which is surprisingly
hard to stop cane F3 and then okay let's
pretend for a second that d8 D7 works it
doesn't
but let's pretend then I will I will do
this and invade and I told you if I play
the move King G5 I'm going to win I
wasn't lying to
you
Invasion can call White you can call
White the British Empire because you
know it's invading my territory
something like that
yeah Rook Rook B5 Rook B5 is the only
past move that
exists right so Rook B5 doesn't change
anything we can Shuffle Rook B5 D5 which
is what I did for a few moves he went to
D4 so now I don't have Rook D5 but Rook
C5 um Rook C5 B5 still exists he played
the move caning G4 obviously if he would
have played keing E3 or E4 what whatever
I would have gone Rook B5 back or
something um although I suppose here we
can consider moves like Rook to C2 for
instance attacking both of these these
guys um although that is dangerous the
reason why I say it's dangerous is if
you do this then your opponent will go
Rook to A4 and you're definitely going
to have to return back Rook to C5 um but
instead he plays King G4 which has the
very obvious threat of King G5 I have to
stop him if he plays King G4 King G5
then it is over so I played
H6 and he plays the move Rook to D2 and
then this is um this is the
main point in the game where you can
make a
draw so black has defended not to like
Pat myself on the back or anything but
black has defended like pretty well uh
under the you know the current
circumstances position is wasn't good
but we we're we're here now black has a
defensible position if you can find
Black's next two moves you will make a
draw and if you don't you will
lose Rook D2 was played because in some
positions we wanted to go Rook C2
obviously and white is just guarding
against that
idea so what about Rook
D5 well Rook D5 again he's going to take
and he will return and this is just a
weakness right so after King so you're a
to get the opposition uh it doesn't
matter if you get the opposition or not
the the the thing that happens to you
okay so first of all it's going to like
you don't have a square
right and the second thing is you have
um a middle pawn and I'm going to create
an outside pass Pawn an outside pass
pawns win kingom Pawn endings so like
you know King C5 or whatever uh like
let's say say that white does everything
in his power not to win the game he
still probably wins uh because you're
going to have to stay Tethered to your
D4 pawn and in the you know in the
meantime he's going to uh create one of
one of these
dudes um and then go for your queen side
right um and that is like the most
inaccurate way that white could possibly
play after King C5 obviously you go King
E4 and the D4 Pawn is going to is going
to drop so King and pawn endings are not
good for you if the structure
changes A4 that is what I played in the
game that is correct okay B captures
A4 now this is a this one one one sec so
oh sorry sorry B4 um is not really a
problem now we can go Rook to B5 white
will protect his pawn and then we'll go
A5 and without the weakness on the queen
side um like takes takes this position
is pretty acceptable for black I think
uh you're going to have to try really
hard to create anything on the king side
black can just like defend on the a file
passively after a move like Rook to D4
for instance like Rook A8 Rook A6 and so
on maybe there are even more accurate
ways to make a draw there like Rook
sorry Rook C4 maybe even black can play
for a win because after A3 Rook C3 A3 is
is loose and okay I mean this is not a
winning attempt right
this is like how people lose chess games
even right so don't go B4 so takes on
A4 and this is a uh a really hard
problem I showed this position to yaser
San and he couldn't believe what the
answer
was so this black to
play and make a
draw you just know yeah that's the
answer A5
very very nice okay but why I played the
move Rook C4 in the
game and um what I was afraid of was the
move Pawn H4 and then Pawn H5 I was I
sorry I wasn't afraid of it but my my
idea was in response to this plan okay
if I take I lose because the can is has
invaded my my territory right if I um
let him take I'm going to lose because
after Pawn takes he goes Rook D6 and my
E Pawn is uh is just dropping off the
board right he's going to have two
connected passers against my a pawn
that's not defensible he's probably
going to end up with three pawns against
my a pawn that's not how you draw a rook
and
games um so if he were to play the move
H5 I would play the move G5 this is
pretty safe the structure is safe right
I'm going to take on F4 the King still
doesn't have a square where it can
penetrate tra my
position so what my opponent does
here is play it's now white to play and
win we'll go back and see why A5 is so
smart white to play and
win and if H if Steph is out there
watching you know uh I I still don't
admit that your rule is any
good even though it 100% works here so
if you were supposed to play A5 and draw
yeah so SSP your opponent's good pawn
move is also your good pawn move so Pawn
to A5 is really smart because after I
play the move Rook A4 which is what I
did in the game he goes H4 takes H5 and
notice where my Rook is not it's not
here which means G5 is impossible he'll
take me so let's go back for one second
before we see uh the result of me not
playing playing A5
um had I played the move A5 this is very
clever white goes H4 Rook C4 I am in no
rush to capture this Pawn on A4 I can
play the move G5 myself the game is a
draw if I had done this I'd be like two
points away from FM right
now um all good it's a it's about the
process um actually just like as an
aside everybody um every body in chess
is worried about all like the wrong
things you know as as you know as normal
um so when you play a chess tournament
is going to make people like
upset that's all luck like how well you
do in the chess tournament is is luck
you don't control how well you play in
the tournament you don't control how
your how well your opponent plays on any
given day you can play plus minus 400
points to your rating right so can your
opponent like people's best tournaments
are when their opponents like neurons
misfire in their brain so where does
like the skill come in chess like it the
skill comes from maintaining your Edge
long term so it doesn't matter how well
you perform like game to game or
tournament to tournament that doesn't
matter what matters is does does your
rating increase over time based off of
your study habits that's where your
edges are found so people shouldn't be
trying to go for like these big you know
like rating games and like massive
tournaments this you know you can't
control that the thing that you can
control is like very slow steady
progress um with with good
study um you know and and that kind of
thing but okay so I'm not like super
concerned about not making FM this
tournament whatever I didn't make FM
this tournament that's that's life um
hopefully I can prove that I'll make F
FM in the long
term okay so my my opponent played the
move A5 here which is really
nice Rook A4
uh H4 and now we are we are losing okay
I took and then played this move F6 I
thought it was being very clever um
let's see if you can figure out the
easiest way to win the game I will no
longer make you see the game from my
perspective it's all over for
me your task is to become Grandmaster
Kaden
trough yeah Kaden is such a nice guy I I
agree it's the worst when you lose to
these like hyper nice people like they
beat you while smiling at you and you
can't hate
them I'd much rather Play Somebody That
like I despise and then when I lose them
I can be like ah I hate that
guy can't hate Kaden it's
impossible rookie so rookie rookie to um
the issue is I will take you and after
you take me back you are letting me
you're kind of letting me in like after
I take um okay Rook A4 is like accurate
to stop your Pawn from coming forward if
I manage to um get my king over here
then maybe I don't
lose maybe I'm sure that move is also
winning to be fair but he he just he
just played in the simplest possible way
this Rook is cutting the king you guys
agree right it's not good for
me so he
plays King takes yeah King takes and
it's just over Pawn takes Pawn takes
sure I have an E Pawn what does that
matter I play the move Rook D5 as like a
bluff it doesn't even matter um after
Rook D5 you could be a psychopath and
calculate Rook takes D5 to its
conclusion or you could be a good chess
player not do
that those are your options I'll
Cate yeah I mean you just
push
what so I mean you check the king push
the oh so he didn't even check me my
king wants to go that way okay so he
wants to create a shield before happens
Rook F2 is a smart idea he played an
even better version of Rook F2 put the
other idea in Lucina which is Rook H2
because he knows that the way I'm going
to defend is by checking him on the H
file so he preemptively puts his Rook on
the H file it's a very nice technique
and it's it's just it's just over I
played for one more trick hoping he
would blunder uh takes takes Queens
queens or or maybe he'll get fancy and
go here and then I win you know a Boy
Can
Dream but uh he played Rook H1 and then
I resigned that's it there are no more
moves to be played if I play Rook to the
D file he plays Kan H7 we're not even
like close to pretending like this is a
defense right black is going to lose uh
trivially so this was a really really
nice game by my opponent and I cannot
stress this enough when you are trying
to improve at chess your wins do not
matter if you had to cut cut off like
your um analysis when it comes to your
win like don't even analyze your wins
only analyze your losses that is what is
you know making your rating go down that
is it is exposing a problem in your
chest um if you had to choose like
analyze your losses for five hours
analyze or analyze your wins for five
hours obviously you should like try to
try to analyze uh your losses um so this
game like showed me something like
pretty important this idea of going uh
A4 and then A5 is really nice uh with
the sole purpose of playing against this
H4 H5 idea
right okay um so I told you guys that at
the start chess is all about pattern
recognition and visualization right okay
now hopefully you guys remember the the
the pattern this is one of my this is
one of my favorite favorite training
positions it is black to
play does Rook takes D2 Win Lose or
draw are you okay if we go like slightly
over time is that okay with you okay all
right oh and um if you think that it
loses uh you can't say oh it loses and
give up you have to give me a different
move which might be
tough there aren't a lot of candidate
moves in this position to be honest with
you
okay what are your
ideas if you play Rook takes Knight
check
reflect yeah so I'm I'm I'm not going to
draw arrows it'll make it too easy
remes PA take the
PA so your variation so far is Rook D2
Queen D2 Queen E4 right
King has to go to H H2
yeah2 H2 yeah
H2 one of those one of the
squares so what do you got you got the
bishop hanging and you've
got okay somebody said Rook F4 Rook F4
Queen B1 which is highly illegal that
was the most illegal variation I've
heard all day Rook F4 Rook F4 Queen
through the pawn taking the rook and
I'll let you do it because I'll play
Knight takes Queen and laugh at
you you're going to cheat cheat better
yeah so play Rook takes
M Rook takes Queen takes Queen takes
Pawn
Che then You'
got
oh I I I see oh chess lover chess lover
was I I understand so both you and chess
lover have the same variation it's Rook
D2 Queen D2 Queen E4 Ken H2 and then you
want Rook F4 and if Rook F4 which is a
good move then Queen B1 what is the
problem with that analysis white to play
and win the game immediately oh check
yeah Rook f8 Checkmate no good
right okay so what should we do
instead okay Rook D2 is the most logical
move it's very forcing Rook D2 Queen D2
Queen E4 Ken H2 Queen uh so so what is
the next the next move you should look
at your opponent you said The Bishop's
hanging right so probably you should
look at taking it yeah so Queen C4 so we
we won two pieces and a pawn for a rook
so far in our analysis if we stop our
analysis here we're doing
great obviously we shouldn't stop our
analysis
the next thing that suggest
something so so hold on you you can't
you can't stop here right so Rook D2
Queen D2 Queen E4 Ken H2 Queen C4
right white has white has forcing moves
and therefore you cannot stop your
analysis if you do stop your analysis
right now you say that black wins
right black has two pieces for a rook
and is equalized the number of Pawns
like black is doing
great so if if we stopped here then you
should play this
variation but white has like a counter
trick that makes it
interesting yeah he has Knight G6 yes G6
yes Knight to G6 which attacks the king
and the Rook right okay so I must
capture your knight and then you will
play Rook takes Rook takes Rook okay I
must play King H7 I have no other
moves Aha and chess lover has has
spotted has spotted the problem so I I
will ask ask the chat chess lover should
know the answer does Rook takes D2 Win
Lose or
Draw
who
the in-house audience is waiting for you
um no let's see if you can you can spot
it though so chess lover says lose that
is correct why why does it lose so Rook
so Rook loses clearly
clearly n G6 Rook f8 because I said so
you can't believe me I'm a liar I'll lie
to you now I'll lie to you again you
heard it here
first
that's right so what move does white
play Queen H6 Queen H6 Rook D2 loses
because of Queen D2 Queen E4 Queen C4
Knight G6 takes Rook f8 Ken H7 Queen H6
now this pattern is not difficult it is
so not difficult that when I put it in
front of you at the start of the lesson
you solved it in like sub five seconds
okay all I did was push the pattern like
like seven moves in the future and then
it became like Blurry and we had to like
work some stuff out
yeah these are two skills you need to
get good at in chess you need to get
good at pattern recognition and need and
you need to get good at visualization
without these two skills um you're going
to be you're going to be uh lost a month
the variations so Rook h8 is mate and
obviously after G takes there I mean you
can block with a bunch of different
things but eventually uh it'll be it'll
be checkmates um bonus points if you can
figure out what Black's best move is is
here the best move um actually I'll give
you like a few minutes to figure that
out and then and then we'll call it a
day so knowing that Rook D2 loses you
figure this all out you see this queen
H6 trap at the end you're like oh no I
get mated well now
what
black has only one move not to
lose I mean your queen is attacked and
your Pawn's
attacked it's tough in a board game
where you know you're only allowed to
make one move per turn if your opponent
attacks more than one thing that's
really
annoying not to like oversimplify it or
anything we don't got to talk about
castlin black is still much worse after
the best move but arguably not
losing and not losing is half the
battle because it gets you half the
point has Bishop C4 been looked at
already you mean from the initial
position Bishop C4 is a legal and bad
you put any Bishop on C4 this is the
funniest because it's the most illegal I
will I will take your queen with
check uh oh hum Bishop
D4 I will take your queen with check put
any Bishop you want on any Square I'll
take your queen with
check a very simple algorithm for that
one Queen D6 Knight D5 Bishop B8
threatening Rook
D2 uh
suspicious Queen here threatening Rook
D2 I don't know about that
one I don't know about that
one so I'm tempted to play Queen to
Queen H6 does not really come with any
Tempo so after Queen H6 your opponent
will probably play Rook B7 and you will
suffer we can play a move that plays for
a trick and tricks are
good okay
Rook well we just determine Rook takes
Knight loses which is highly unfortunate
Rook takes the other Knight oh man no
but I'll take
you
play like Bishop E3 or
something actually wait a second
E5 but's Queen yeah there's a queen
queen here Bishop E3 we can take it so I
yeah Rook takes Knight just doesn't work
concretely there they found it in chat
Queen F6 exclam maybe double exclam the
point of this move is if you play Queen
takes F6 there's Rook D2
check and then black actually wins the
game so white has to play some passive
defensive move and then we can start
thinking about active play like Bishop
E3 for instance or Knight or Knight D4
or even maybe you know we can get greedy
with the move uh Knight takes A5 point
being Queen F6 saves Black's life
because we are gaining the initiative
back although uh White still has a
really nice position um and if you play
the move Rook takes D2 even in a
tournament game you might be thinking oh
maybe my opponent doesn't see Queen H6
the pattern's really easy once we get to
the end you kind of force your opponent
to play all the moves like on accident
like you could see nothing you're like
uh I recapture you're like dang that
sucks I guess I'll move my caning uh hey
look that's a trick and they're like and
they're like hm that kind of that kind
of sucks kingh K
H7 oh
Checkmate you know on accident they can
just like find all these moves um but
anyway the the main lesson I want you
guys to take away from from this class
is please analyze your losses they are
going to be um uh that's going to be the
absolute best thing you can do for your
chess Improvement and um uh and yeah
thank you for uh attending my class uh
on the road to 2000
thank you jul I think I just P
up5 let's hope so we're
[Music]
good